[Music]
for over four billion years the earth
and the moon have traced to delicate
dance around the Sun
but our celestial partner is gradually
slipping away sometimes we talk about
things that are reliable we say there's
nothing as reliable as the rising of the
Sun right we could think of the mood in
the same way it goes through its phase
this is there night after night year
after year but it turns out the moon is
actually moving away from the earth and
that's due to the interaction of the
moon and the Earth's tidal bulge the
Bulge of water
pulled up by gravity sits slightly ahead
of the moon because the Earth spins
faster than the moon orbits the moon
pulls by gravity on that bulge and slows
the Earth's rotation over billions of
years that is slowed the Earth's
rotation a lot we used to be spinning a
lot more rapidly probably more than
twice as fast as we do now
but like a gravitational wit line the
moon's attraction to the Bulge also
speeds up its orbit this speed makes the
moon's orbit wider pushing it farther
and farther away it's very small amount
so it's only about 3.8 centimeters which
is about an inch and a half a year over
billions of years the moon will shrink
to a dot in the night sky and the
Earth's spin will become so slow that
the moon will appear to freeze above our
heads there will come a time where the
earth is actually locked one side of the
earth faces one side of the moon and the
two of them will go around in lockstep
so there'll be one place on earth where
you can see the moon so you might
imagine you'd have to go on some kind of
vacation to actually see the moon at
that point in time but that's gonna be a
long time from now so so you know I
wouldn't start booking your tickets
quite
[Music]
you